えーと 予定の時間は過ぎておりますが
もしよろしければ何かご質問ありましたら挙手をお願いいたします
どうぞ  えっと 不満が生きていくエネルギーだとおっしゃったんですけど
解脱した完全無執着な人の生きていくエネルギーっていうのは何なのか
その不満との関わりで
もう言葉にならないんですよ
だから生きてないんです
不満が生きてるエネルギーだから
それ完全に消したらもう生きてないんです
だからもう涅槃に入ったら
もう誰にもどうすることも
もう認識することもできないんだから
それは人間の認識範囲を超えてるんだから
そこはやめてちょうだいと
しかし 最高な幸福は解脱と涅槃であると
我々も不満がなくなった瞬間で楽しいんだからね
それは極限に不満がなくなったら極限に楽しいんです
しかし そこは生きるってことはない
存在はなし 輪廻転生もなし
生まれることも死ぬこともないというんですよ
だからそんな言葉の遊びで理解できない
で 悟っても涅槃に入られてない場合はね
いわゆる悟った人がまだ生きている場合は
まあ普通に生きてるんですよ
その時は衝動にするのは慈しみなんですね
人々もできる範囲で助けてあげなくちゃいけないんだというね
あの側変で言ったような感じで
ただ生きてみるだけの話なんですね
その場合は 今おっしゃったことは
もう知識が認識概念は超えています
他にございませんでしょうか
どうぞ  全ての宗教は人間が作り出したものだと理解するようになってきましたけど
人間の不満が作り出したと理解してよろしい
うーん ちょっと聞き取れなかったね
全ての宗教は人間の不満が作り出したというふうに理解してよろしいのでしょうか
はい まあそうなんですよ
だから不満だからなんとかしなくちゃいけないというね
ことは出てくるんですよ
例えば人が死ぬは 自分希望通りにいかないわ
それを見ると なんとか自分で管理できない法則があるんじゃないかなと思ったりして
じゃあこの法則に従えばいいんじゃないか
そうやっていろいろ考えちゃうんですよ
もうお釈迦様にしたっても
生きることは苦だ もうどうにもならん
これは嫌だということで修行に励んで悟り開いちゃったんですよ
だからまあ不満が作り出すんですよ
仏教さえも  他の方よろしいですか
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 義の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれた徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の人々生きるものに回向いたします
この徳によって 全ての人々生きるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サンビーテヨ ヴィワジャントゥ サッブロゴー ウィナッセトゥ マテー バワトゥアンテラヨ スッキーディーガ
ユコ ババ ババトゥ サッブマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブデワター サッブ ブッダヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッ
ティ バワントゥテー ババトゥ サッブマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブデワター サッブ ダンマヌバーヴェーナ
サダー スッティ バワントゥテー ババトゥ サッブマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッブデワター サッブ サンガヌバーヴェ
ーナ サダー スッティ バワントゥテー アビワダネ シーリッソ ニッチャン ワッダーパチャイノ チャッターロ
ダンマ ワッダンティ アユワッノー スカン バラン アユーラーローグヤ サンパッティ サッブ サンパッティ メーワチ
ャ アトー ニッバーナ サンパッティ イミナーテー サミッジャトゥ
はい どうもありがとうございます
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ